[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello hello
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Sheena Takahashi and
I'll be your guide for today's Nintendo
Direct
[Music]
that was the latest trailer for Pikmin
4.
a dog-like creature was spotted what
kinds of things will it show us
please look forward to more information
in the future
let's see our first batch of Nintendo
switch headlines
this new hero is a real gem
introducing volume 3 of the Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 expansion pass DLC
laughterist extraordinaire
say hello to Masha the newest hero and a
refined lapidarist
[Music]
special ore to craft accessories that
can bestow various effects
challenge battles with roguelike
elements are also being added select
only one character and battle wave after
wave of enemies
for every win you'll learn more Heroes
and special abilities
rack up victories With Your Heroes and
set your sights on the final stage
you might also get special in-game
outfits as a reward
and coming in volume 4 later this year
tell me why
is this really what you want nothing's
gonna get through to him he's a
heartless machine
[Music]
that killing Granddad wasn't enough for
you volume 3 of the Xenoblade Chronicles
3 expansion pass for the Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 game Launches on the
Nintendo switch system February 15th
[Music]
shake it amigo
eat in a brand new Samba de Amigo game
grab your joy-con controllers and gently
shake them like Maracas to match the
targets during a song
[Music]
follow the instructions on screen to
pose
and dance
but the unexpected might happen so stay
on your toes
why not dance with a friend to predict
your compatibility in love Checker
make sure to show up in style too
compete online in world party those with
the lowest scores in each round will be
eliminated keep the beat and aim for
first place
40 songs are included spanning a
multitude of genres from around the
world
so grab those controllers and get shaken
when Samba de Amigo party central shimmy
sun to Nintendo switch this summer
[Music]
got a passion for fashion
welcome to Fashion dreamer this is the
place to Glam it up and express yourself
here you'll aim to become a stylish
influencer and you're in luck tons of
people are seeking the latest trends
give them a like if you dig their Style
or suggest new outfits for them to grow
as an influencer
now it's time for fashion design
[Music]
choose from over 1 000 design options
then add a personal touch to give your
item a final flourish
you can get the items other people are
wearing by liking them
mix and match your favorites to create
new looks
connecting online you can expand your
friend Circle and grow your brand
got an eye for fashion then get styling
when fashion dreamer debuts exclusively
on Nintendo switch this year
[Music]
delve into these Dark Worlds
Dracula's castle beckons in this new
paid DLC for the roguelite action
platformer dead cells
Venture through the Castle's hellish
halls and outskirts alongside Richter
Belmont and Alucard leading up to a
showdown with death and Dracula himself
wield the Vampire Killer and other
iconic weapons as you Vanquish Legions
of monsters and frenetic combat 12
original covers and 51 Songs From the
Castlevania series accompany you during
your quest in dead cells return to
Castlevania sinking its teeth into
Nintendo switch March 6th pre-orders
begin today on Nintendo eShop
enter a new Grid in this narrative
puzzle Adventure set within the Tron
Universe uncover dangerous truths and
retrieve what was lost as you navigate
through a perilous world
your decisions and the alliances you
forge will impact your journey and the
entire server
Tron identity launches first for
consoles on Nintendo switch this April
who's there
wait is that
well that can't be good the time-bending
murder mystery Ghost Trick returns in HD
after kicking the bucket and becoming a
ghost you can possess and control
objects with your powers you can even
help others like this woman and change
any ill-fated
uh thanks
Ghost Trick Phantom detective Spirits
onto Nintendo switch this summer
[Music]
two connected worlds one suspenseful
Thriller
[Applause]
[Music]
click on them
foreign
[Music]
once upon a time there was a witch and a
demon
experience bayonetta's Origins as a
young witch named cereza
seeking the power to rescue her
imprisoned mother she Ventures deep into
the Avalon Forest ruled by fairies I'm
going to that Forest
I'm going to become a witch and save
money
there she'll encounter the otherworldly
demon Cheshire
[Music]
you'll control both witch and Demon at
the same time harness erases magic and
cheshire's ferocity to travel through
this mysterious and dangerous Forest
they'll need to work together in battle
as well
[Music]
ceresa cannot attack and can only
support Cheshire by magically binding
enemies hold an enemy in place while
Cheshire attacks
or stop an aggressive one to focus on
another
strategically use each character's
abilities to win battles
[Music]
the duo will gain strength as they
continue their journey by obtaining more
Powers New Paths can be opened and
battles can be more easily swayed in
your favor
Ken cereza and Cheshire find their
happily ever after
Bayonetta Origins cereza and the lost
demon prowls onto the Nintendo switch
system March 17th pre-orders are
available now on Nintendo eShop
how was that
next please take a look at this
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
expansion pass this paid DLC includes
two waves of content
the first wave is incopolis make this
splat-tastic place from the original
Splatoon game your stomping grounds
this is booyah base it's got some pretty
nifty weapons and gear you might spot a
few familiar faces alongside new
shopkeepers
products here are the same as the ones
in splatsville so shop wherever your
Vibes are strongest
salmon runs
table Turf battle the show and amiibo
functionality all work in the same way
here too
[Music]
the squid sisters will also perform here
during splatfests
need a mix of old school and freshness
then head over to inkopolis
[Music]
first wave of this paid DLC launches
this spring
[Music]
oh what's this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
launches this spring
Wave 2 side order will launch in the
future
[Music]
the Splatoon 3 expansion packs will be
available later today on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
many people have played Splatoon 3 since
its launch
thank you all very much
we hope players will be able to enjoy
the game even more with the upcoming
paid expansion pass
please look forward to more information
about Splatoon 3 in the future
let's see some more Nintendo switch
headlines
Adventure awaits Mickey and friends on
illusion Island
Mickey Mouse Minnie Mouse Donald Duck
and goopy
embark on a new adventure to find three
magical books and save the mysterious
island of manoth
run
jump
and swing to explore every nook and
cranny of the island
[Music]
by unlocking special abilities you can
reach new places and find secret areas
cross large chasms with Boost jump
ground pound barriers to open new spaces
and glide through the air to reach
distant platforms and hidden areas each
character's personality shines through
in their actions up to four Pals locally
can Brave the island share a hug for
extra health
play leapfrog for larger jumps or drop a
rope to lend a hand
work together to save Manoff and you
might discover New Paths
while exploring the island you'll meet
unusual allies and dangerous foes
study their movements carefully to
figure out the secrets to Victory
join Nikki and friends on a high flying
Adventure in Disney illusion Island
swinging onto Nintendo switch July 28th
pre-orders begin today on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
more emblems are on the way
new emblems are coming to Future waves
of the Fire Emblem and gauge expansion
pass DLC Wave 2 includes Hector emblem
of strength Ray's defense and unleash
counter-attacks there is only one person
emblem of Acumen cast magic spells over
a wide area
[Music]
Camilla emblem of Revelation modify the
terrain to hinder enemies
wave three includes
krom and Robin emblem of bonds
overwhelmed foes with sword and Magic
attacks
Veronica emblem of Heroes
I see you summon additional allies to
fight for your cause
challenge newly added missions to
recruit these new emblems
and in Wave 4 a new story called Bell
xenologue will be unlocked
thank you for answering our prayers I've
always said that's putting your world in
danger now watch out assassins
will engage expansion pass for the Fire
Emblem engage game Launches on the
Nintendo switch system later today
[Music]
take control of your destiny
this is reverie a world in which deities
known as aspirations dwell
when a megacorp endangers the harmony
between reverie and our world the future
of humanity hangs in the balance
narrative Adventure harness Your Divine
gift of Clairvoyance to travel between
worlds
see the future
and decide Humanity's fate many
branching story paths along with a
riveting soundtrack by Celeste composer
Lena Rayne set the stage for your
journey eventually you'll side with one
of the six aspirations like Bond
power or chaos to change the story's
outcome to which Destiny do you Aspire
Harmony the fall of reverie launches
first for consoles on Nintendo switch
this June
[Music]
these games will have you rolling
octopath traveler 2 is just around the
corner
after today's Nintendo Direct a demo
containing the game's opening hours will
be available on Nintendo eShop
eight new stories await which path will
you take first who will your allies be
and where will your journey lead you
venture through a brand new world in
octopath traveler 2 launching a Nintendo
switch February 24th keep it rolling run
around and collect Oodles of objects in
this remaster of we love Katamari
roll in a classroom a zoo and space
new features include playing as the
young king of all Cosmos and five new
challenges
and taking photos with a selfie camera
we love Katamari reroll Plus Royal
reverie comes to Nintendo switch June
2nd in addition active Nintendo switch
online members can play a free game
trial of Katamari damashiri roll
combine the powers of the sun and moon
to fend off evil in this turn-based RPG
freely Traverse a breathtaking World
meet characters from all walks of life
and devastate foes with timed attacks in
battle
complement your journey with enchanting
Melodies and retro inspired Tunes from
the renowned yasunori mitsuda a guest
composer for the game
sea of stars sails onto Nintendo switch
August 29th
a free demo will launch later today on
Nintendo eShop
duke it out in this free to play online
multiplayer Showdown
form two teams of three and challenge
others to lightning fast battles air
hockey Style
use each Striker's skills to dominate
each match
change the course trajectory from afar
block areas to gain the advantage
or knock opponents out of the arena with
explosive moves
Omega Strikers slides onto Nintendo
switch April 27th pre-orders for this
free-to-play game begin today on
Nintendo eShop
[Music]
dive back into the sprawling Labyrinth
a collection of the first three etrian
Odyssey games is coming to Nintendo
switch remastered in HD many Treasures
lie deep within a massive Labyrinth its
paths are intertwined and vicious
monsters lurk in the shadows a blank map
is your only guide
by drawing the map as you explore you
can progress even further
Venture into the Labyrinth with five
adventurers as the guild leader you'll
assign them roles like the Ally
defending protector or the ultra fast
dark Hunter
but be warned every Adventure is brought
with danger
should you fall in battle you can change
your team and learn new skills to
strengthen your party before challenging
the Labyrinth again
24 newly drawn character illustrations
are included
plus take advantage of new difficulty
options and a new auto mapping function
for smoother exploration
etrian Odyssey Origins collection
Launches on Nintendo switch June 1st
each game in the collection will also be
available separately on Nintendo eShop
pre-orders begin today on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
your Tactical skills ready
calling all strategy fans the Advanced
Wars OnePlus 2 reboot Camp games only a
couple of months away join Andy Max
Sammy and More in two full story
campaigns each one filled with colorful
turn-based tactical action
flex your strategic muscles across a
multitude of modes design your own maps
and share them with friends plus go head
to head in local and online play
Advanced Wars OnePlus 2 reboot Camp
comes to Nintendo switch April 21st
pre-orders begin today on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
a new story will unfold in the Kirby's
Return to Dreamland Deluxe game
magolor The interdimensional Traveler
from the main Adventure has lost his
powers and must escape the realm between
dimensions
[Music]
thank you
all he can do now is a basic attack and
jump
to regain magalore's Powers you'll need
to collect magic points by defeating
enemies
with magic points different abilities
can be restored and enhanced
improve magalore's levitation
or increase his attack range the order
in which you restore his powers is up to
you
there are over 20 interdimensional
stages to explore
foreign
[Music]
system can Venture through this
mysterious realm together
[Music]
Ken magalore restore his powers and
safely Return To His World you
can access this new epilogue after
clearing story mode
after today's Nintendo Direct a demo
will be available on Nintendo eShop
[Music]
up to four players can play a specially
arranged demo with select stages and sub
games
Kirby's Return to Dreamland Deluxe
Launches on the Nintendo switch system
February 24th pre-orders are available
now on Nintendo eShop
we hope you're looking forward to the
new story in Kirby's Return to Dreamland
Deluxe
next here's some news about Nintendo
switch online please take a look at this
Game Boy games are being added to
Nintendo switch online
on Nintendo switch you can play these
games anytime anywhere just like you
could back in the day
let's introduce the games that will be
available at launch
[Music]
Tetris arrange the falling tetraminos
and aim for a high score
[Music]
Mario Land 2 6 golden coins reclaim the
castle that Wario stole from you
The Legend of Zelda Link's Awakening DX
awaken the wind fish to escape covalent
Island
[Music]
gargoyle's Quest save the ghoul realm
Aspire brand from The Ghost and Goblin
series
Game and Watch gallery 3 play an
assortment of Game and Watch titles
alone in the dark the new nightmare
solve a murder mystery on the
supernatural Shadow Island Metroid 2
return of Samus destroy the metroids
hiding on planet Sr 388
Wario Land 3 Traverse a world that
changes between day and night based on
your actions
Kirby's Dreamland
bloke inhale and spit out enemies in
Kirby's debut title
[Music]
you can use the Game Boy
Game Boy Pocket
or Game Boy Color screen filters up to
two players can play compatible games
together locally or online
more games will be added in the future
[Music]
and
foreign
Boy advanced games are being added to
Nintendo switch online plus expansion
pack
here are the games that you can play at
launch
[Music]
Super Mario Advance 4 Super Mario
Brothers 3 play 38 extra levels from the
Nintendo e-Reader accessory
WarioWare Inc mega micro games
experience the origins of the Lightning
Fast micro games
[Music]
guide the spinning stick to the goal
without hitting obstacles
Mario Kart super Circuit race in the
first Mario Kart game created for a
portable system
Mario and Luigi Superstar Saga Venture
through a zany world and fight with
equally zany attacks
[Music]
The Legend of Zelda the Minish Cap
shrink to miniature size and dive into a
big adventure
[Music]
local and online play is supported for
compatible games and up to four players
can play together
[Music]
more games will be added to this Library
as well
[Music]
after this presentation you can play
these Game Boy titles with the Nintendo
switch online membership
or play both Game Boy and Game Boy
advanced titles with the Nintendo switch
online plus expansion pack membership
Game Boy titles
will be playable on Nintendo switch
and after today's Nintendo Direct you'll
be able to play the game boy and Game
Boy Advance titles we introduced
please look forward to more information
about Nintendo switch online and
Nintendo switch online plus expansion
pack in the future
let's see a few more headlines
the original Metroid Prime game is
remastered on Nintendo switch
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the first Metroid Prime game originally
released on the Nintendo GameCube system
has been remastered for Nintendo switch
explore Talon 4 from the perspective of
Samus Aaron but beware there's more to
this alien planet that meets the eye
visors are the key to your adventure
they'll help you discover info and clues
on how to progress
pending on the situation A Certain visor
may be required
when hostile creatures attack keep them
in your sights with a lock-on feature
then fight back with beams missiles
bumps and more
this remaster adds new dual stick
controls allowing you to move around
while separately changing your point of
view
you can also select a control style that
recreates the feel of the original game
among other control options explore
Talon 4 with your preferred play style
the digital version of Metroid Prime
remastered Launches on Nintendo eShop
later today the physical version of the
game will be available in stores
February 22nd
[Music]
put your master detective skills to the
test
this is the world detective organization
Yuma a trainee detective and Shinigami
the spirit haunting him will solve the
strange incidents within Kanye Ward a
city ruthlessly controlled by Amaterasu
Corporation
you'll investigate these incidents
alongside Master detectives of the
organization each one has a supernatural
ability that can prove useful during
investigations
mimic body types and voices with
disguise
detect heartbeats and Whispers with
audio aptitude
and witness past crime scenes with post
cognition these abilities can be shared
with Yuma so this is post cognition so
use them to get closer to cracking a
case after collecting enough evidence a
mystery Labyrinth will appear
[Music]
spot the inconsistencies and uncover the
truth
Master detective archives raincoat
Launches on Nintendo switch June 30th
[Music]
wings of the Heart Take Flight once more
a remastered collection of both button
kaido's games originally released on the
Nintendo GameCube system is coming to
Nintendo switch after a long and
peaceful era on the floating islands
above Earth the Empire's conspiracy
looms closer as Spirits dwelling within
the protagonists
[Music]
you'll stand up to the Empire across two
different eras of War
travels you
'll Miss locales and team up with
like-minded allies
battles are fought using cards called
Magnus
your attack power is determined by the
attributes and combinations of your
cards which are randomly dealt from the
deck
in these real-time battles you'll need
to make split-second decisions to Edge
closer to Victory what Revelations will
come to light in the skies above and the
lands below
thoten kaidos 1 and 2 HD remaster soars
onto Nintendo switch this summer
[Music]
dive into your new Fantasy Life
live the life you want in a new Fantasy
Life game
while exploring the once thriving Island
you'll meet a mysterious girl
then travel between past and present
to make the island your own
become a wood cutter angler
cook blacksmith
Paladin magician and more
take on different roles to develop the
island
how will you rebuild
this life is yours to live
[Music]
after one thousand years the restoration
is about to begin
Fantasy Life off the girl who steals
time
[Music]
wave four is racing in
Yoshi's Island a brand new course is
zooming into wave four of the Mario Kart
8 Deluxe Booster course pass DLC
[Music]
Birdo who originally hit the track in
Mario Kart Double Dash is also being
added to wave 4.
foreign
[Music]
wave four of the Mario Kart 8 Deluxe
Booster course pass DLC for the Mario
Kart 8 Deluxe game races onto the
Nintendo switch system this spring
active Nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack members can enjoy this
DLC at no additional cost the DLC can
also be purchased on its own
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
thank you
thank you for staying with us so far
this will be our last segment please
take a look
[Music]
rise rise my servants
sweep over Hyrule eliminate this Kingdom
and her allies
leave no survivors
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
but link I am not sure you'll be able to
stop him
[Music]
foreign
please lend him your power
[Music]
that was The Legend of Zelda tears of
the Kingdom the latest entry in The
Legend of Zelda series
[Music]
in addition to the standard version a
collector's edition of the game
containing various items will release on
launch day a new amiibo figure of link
from this game will also be available on
the same day
we hope you are looking forward to
Link's latest Grand Adventure
that's all for today's Nintendo Direct
thank you for watching